there are some people who are taking
issue with your assessment that sean
watson currently is the best deep ball
thrower in the national football league
all time your pick was warren moon right
now it's desean watson and some folks
out there will quibble with that and say
it's patrick mahomes first and foremost
russell wilson gets plenty of votes some
think kirk cousins ryan tannehill of all
people um what are your thoughts on some
of the reactions you have seen to the
folks who have disagreed with your
assessment that desean watson throws the
prettiest deep ball right now well
that's fine but see that's where at
first that's where we got to clear the
air a little bit we did a draft on
prettiest deep ball right and when we
said best on instagram there we just met
like best looking listen i didn't want
to i love deshaun watson and listen i
think he's very close in the class
of the guys i'm about to mention
now deshawn watson to me throws the
prettiest deep ball because he throws it
really high he can really spin it hard
he can throw perfect spirals that's why
i took him on same thing for warren moon
now listen if it was third and nine and
i go oh i need a deep ball thrown for a
completion i would think about watson
don't get me wrong but i'm going with
patrick mahomes and then i'm probably
going to go with my buddy aaron rodgers
after that same thing with warren moon
love the way it looked in person with
warren moon
have seen it it's amazing but again if
it was 1989 and it was third and 12 and
i needed a bomb completed i'm gonna pick
john elway it's not i don't mean that i
just that's where i think we got a
little off-kilter now the default
conversation in itself is a really good
conversation it is and what is a deep
ball you know hey doug ferrar he wrote
this article right for usa today and he
does a great job he's a good good dude i
really respected him and he brought in
the analytics of you know who actually
are the best deep ball throwers in the
nfl and those type of things it's a
great discussion numbers don't tell the
whole story there listen the numbers
will tell you patrick mahomes is the
best deep ball thrower and he is there's
no doubt about that but do i think other
guys numbers would be similar to would
desean watson's deep ball numbers be
similar to patrick mahomes if he had
tyree kill sammy watkins andy reed and
and uh travis kelsey work in the field i
do certainly so it's more about what's
being asked of the quarterback the
talent around them the running game the
past protection and then when we defined
deep ball part of this process was like
20 yard deep balls you know that's not a
deep ball that's an intermediate pass to
me
right there i'm talking 40 times i'm out
go ahead start time out and and that's
where i'm confused because you were
giving examples earlier if it's third
and nine i'll take patrick holmes third
and twelve give me john that way
we need to be on the same page about
what we mean when we say deep ball
because i'll see the analytics and and
the advanced stats and it's it's balls
that travel 20 yards in the air i mean
to me the deep ball it's like i said
last week it's that moment when you're
watching a game on tv and it's one of
the great things about watching football
on tv because when that ball gets sent
soaring into the air you have no idea
who's gonna be there when it comes down
and you marvel at the flight and you
wonder what happens when interview comes
the receiver the defensive back how many
defensive backs how many receivers how
far apart will they be is he going to
catch it is he not going to catch it is
it going to be intercepted i mean the
the possibilities they aren't quite
limitless but you get my point that's to
me a deep ball when you go back and you
fire it long and high and out of the
screen and we have no idea where it's
going to land that's a deep ball to me
that agreed that's that's really what we
were talking about and you know listen i
understand there's like what we would
call quick fades in the nfl and things
like that where uh it's like a 20 25
yard completion it's kind of like a a
quicker arc deep ball that's what doug
farrar is talking about but that's
different as far as what our
conversation was and you know again
statistically with some of this stuff
too you know a lot of the things i
mentioned are going to play within the
numbers uh you know and however you want
to analyze a deep ball thrower to begin
with you know again desean watson let's
just let's see so numbers and
statistically lamar jackson is a better
deep ball thrower than desean watson i
love lamar jackson there's no way on any
day of the week he's a better deep ball
thrower than deshawn watson his numbers
will be of course when it's up the
middle for mark ingram for eight uh you
know lamar jackson around the edge for
15. mark ingram up the middle for 15.
lamar jackson up the middle for 12. now
there's 10 guys within six feet of the
line of scrimmage and they're all going
we got to stop the run this offensive
line's huge they have two tight ends in
the game they have three tight ends in
the game and then as you see in this
highlight here there's a hollywood brown
running down the field with nobody in
the screen because everybody's worried
about the run game so that of course is
going to lead to better numbers and i'm
not saying this to you know crap on
lamar jackson you know i think he's the
man i know you think he's the man but
the point is the numbers don't tell the
whole story with this type of thing
where deshawn watson is in the shotgun
every play every play is sending people
deep the offense isn't known to be like
the most creative in football it's
dependent on watson making deep ball
throws oh and this just in the defenses
know that so they're worried about the
deep ball there's no run game in houston
that people are like oh my gosh that's
scary let alone we've been talking about
lack of pass protection for deshaun
watson for the last four years so that's
my point you know that's that's all i'm
saying it's a great conversation there's
a lot of ways to break it down watson to
me is one of the best there is out there
but no i'm not going to take them over
my homes or rogers quite yet or russell
wilson because that they're russell
wilson's an unbelievable deep ballpark
too
i think if i can summarize the
disconnect it is that we were having a
very subjective
qualitative discussion last week about
how they look how the ball looks how the
play looks look at that's pretty cool
statistical
analytics you know ball travels through
the air x number of yards and no this is
just the ball that soars and that really
wasn't even a deep ball it looked good
i'm talking about the guy goes back sets
his feet and lets it fly that to me is a
deep ball it always has been and always
will be a deep ball you know and uh is
there anything about the way you throw
it that enhances the ability to catch it
it's not like it's coming in you know
like a a freaking laser it's not coming
in it's gonna break your fingers like a
john elway fastball would do or the old
elway cross where it would leave a
bruise on your chest in the in the shape
of the indentation where the four panels
of leather come together is there
anything that makes a deep ball more
catchable
yeah well definitely there is you know
and of course you know the big thing and
i know we discussed this a little last
week is to throw the ball high you know
when you throw the ball high you're in
the advantage there one there's
less there's more room for error right
because you're not trying to hit a
bullseye or hit a guy right between the
two numbers you know the other thing is
wide receivers are much better and
adjusting to the football than dbs so
when you throw the ball high that way
too they're going to understand how to
play that ball where the db is going to
panic to death and he's a db and that's
the reason he is a db is because he
could he couldn't catch the ball that
great as a young kid or whatever it may
be so he's panicking and that's not in
his like you know natural state there
either but the big thing is to to throw
the ball high and deep and the great
ones that really do that whether that's
mahomes or watson they look you got to
look high and look to throw the ball
high so if i was going to throw a deep
ball mic you know a little bit like you
and i when we've had a toss together
first off you're going to get your
shoulder in there right you're going to
get your shoulder in there but you
really want to throw it up and have your
arm go up to the trajectory of what you
want to throw the football and where
that's going to make that more catchable
for people you're going to get more of
this type of thing where the ball is
going to go up and then the ball will do
what we call in the nfl turn over and it
will fall down nose first and if you
could throw a perfect spiral with the
nose coming down like that it's
basically like bread into a basket and
the receiver can run and the ball just
falls seamlessly right into his two
hands and makes it very easy to catch
that way and to me that's what the
really really great deep ball throwers
do you know there's some that don't look
up mike or put their body up to throw
the ball there they might just look at
the receiver and then just use their arm
to try to throw it up and i want to go
well you know you got to look to where
you're going to throw the football and
the trajectory where you want to throw
it you're not going to get the results
you want if you do it that way
and you know it just shows you the
benefit and the value and the importance
of working with your receivers
they have to run those routes over and
over again i'm sure for every receiver
it's a different it's a different target
it's a different trajectory it's a
different touch it's a different release
it's not not you know i don't want to
get that complicated with it but i'm
sure that when you're throwing to joey
galloway versus
some other guy who isn't joey galloway
you've got a different approach
altogether on how you throw the deep
ball
no doubt you're right i mean i'll take
two guys that i played with in tampa if
i had keyshawn johnson and joey galloway
i was gonna throw the deep balls
different to them it depended you know
with the keyshawn johnson i might have
thrown it high but more into the way of
i think he's going to go up and catch it
like a jump ball type of catch right
because keyshawn's not famous for his
game breaking speed or he's not going to
like outrun people with the ball in his
hair i would have thrown it that way
with joey galloway i would have just
gone man let me just throw it high and
throw it to an area and those three
rockets up his butt will ignite and
he'll fly over there and get it make me
look good and that's what you can do
with a really good player like a tyree
kill think about mahomes in the game uh
in the super bowl two jet wasp right he
throws the ball as tyree kills just
coming out of his break but he goes man
if i throw this ball high enough into
this general area i know that fast
little freak over there is gonna go get
that ball and make it look easy and
that's uh your very right to that point
the wide receiver who you're throwing to
is gonna be dependent on how you throw
the football to a man i look good with
that hair damn i'm handsome yeah yeah
yeah
man i love it i love it when we have the
b-roll of you firing that ball deep i
mean that's exactly that that's a
beautiful deep ball
thank you hey listen one of my
one of my career accomplishments is i
have a
an article that somebody framed for me
and john gruden made a comment at the
end of a training cramp practice that my
arm was better than brett favre
and i framed that thing and i love i
look at it just to make myself feel good
my arm was not as good as brett favre i
had a really good arm but that was one
of my favorite quotes ever from john
gordon
i think i think john green may have had
some bad pizza delivered to his hotel
room the night before that's the only
explanation that i have for that one
delusional
uh but but not but but look it's it's
you've got to have that in your arsenal
we talk all the time about having
receivers who can stretch the field to
open up the rest of the offense well if
you don't have a quarterback that can
take advantage of the receiver who
stretches the field it isn't going to
open up the rest of the offense you've
got to be able to periodically throw it
deep even if you don't connect you've
got to keep the defense concerned about
getting burned deep it's like having the
ball hit over your head when you're
playing baseball you don't want that to
happen and the farther you go back the
more you're concerned about that that
area right chris the the harder the more
you do that the easier it is to find
everything underneath
that's right it goes back again to our
old conversation of defending every
square inch of the field
and really that's what the really great
quarterbacks do more times than not
because they have that ability to make
those big time throws deep down the
field like you're saying with their body
not being in perfect position or people
around them in the pocket and they still
can do it and it puts tremendous
pressure on the defense you know that's
to me one of the beauties of it desean
watson you know it's a good conversation
hey look mike just even even in this
like
with with desean watson he's 38 of 84 on
deep balls right and he threw it for
1313 yards and 11 touchdowns now that's
pretty that's pretty good that's
explosive okay you know dak prescott is
ranked above him right with
with 35 completions on 76 attempts so
what i'm saying to you mike too is
would you rather have dak prescott stats
where it's three less completions on
eight less incompletions or would you
rather have desean watson's three more
completions for 163 more yards
and eight more incompletions to me
i'd rather have the desean watson thing
it's it shows you how much pressure he's
putting on you on a defense and it kind
of tells you how they're calling and
playing the game along with it
it's an interesting conversation
there was a game years ago and an
analyst who shall remain nameless was
offering up a very clumsy effort to
explain how
it's good to throw the deep ball
uh even if it's incomplete and i think
the point was and the point should be
that it is the threat of the deep ball
the the fact that you use that play
that helps your offense what i was
saying earlier you keep the defense
honest deep
and it allows you to do things short and
do you think enough teams really do
just you know just first in 10 right
from the 35 yard line your own 35 yard
line starting a drive first and ten
why run it for two yards why not why not
do a little play action and fire it deep
just to wake them up
just to keep them thinking it may be
coming again and that may help your
offense the rest of the day
no no doubt mike i think yes and we're
in the era where we're obsessed with
quarterback completion percentage and i
want to go man you show me a quarterback
that's thrown for 73 or 74 i'll show you
an offense that nobody's really that
scared of that's what i'll show you you
know yeah and we've seen hey the saints
are a great example of that seems like
when they get against a good defense or
anything like that and they have a
little understanding of sean payton's
offense well all of a sudden all those
short completions that we see
that are wide open they're not open and
it's because teams are going we don't
think drew brees can throw the ball that
deep nor do we think you have a receiver
that's scary that deep either so we're
going to play five and ten yard routes
and be all over that stuff so
you know a lot of the really explosive
offenses we saw last year hey listen
aaron rodgers and green bay they'll do
what you're talking about same with
russell wilson and island seattle i
would say they need to do it more you
know obviously and we know kansas city
will do that as well but there is
there's value to it it's not always like
you're saying about the completion and
making it happen it's saying hey back
off us defense and we will go deep and
we're not scared to do that and it
really helps open and facilitate other
things within your offense
yeah we talk a lot about the guessing
game that is always there for a defense
is it a run is it a pass well if it's a
pass what kind of a pass is it going to
be
make them defend the whole field that's
why the chiefs are so good have them
always thinking they're going to get
burned deep makes it easier to find the
guy in the seam the guy in the flat the
guy in the crossing pattern etc and you
keep the chains moving that way and then
when they start to close in that's when
you get them over the top that's part of
the beauty of a great offensive design
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports